joining us now with no reaction all this
breaking news Republican Congressman Jim
Jordan Jim you watched the events unfold
today you just heard John's report your
reaction well the first thing is Bob
Miller Bob moles report if the report
speaks for itself why'd you have to do a
press conference and what did we learn
in the nine minutes and 39 seconds of
mr. molars press conference we've
learned that there was no collusion no
obstruction after what 22 months thirty
million dollars 19 lawyers 40 FBI agents
500 witnesses 2,800 subpoenas it was the
same darn conclusion so that to me was
the big takeaway if the report speaks
for itself why did you have to do a 9
minute 39 second press conference where
you took no questions from the press you
know maybe Jim Jordan I've read too many
of the closed-door testimonies to see
what people like yourself and Mark
Meadows were doing behind the scenes
now the congressman Doug Collins release
the closed-door testimony the question
you and others would ask mark Meadows
would ask were poignant they were
relevant and they got to the facts
I don't think Bob Muller would want to
go before you I have a lot of questions
about Bob Bob mow when did he know that
there was no collusion I'd like to know
how he was interested in fairer and loan
applications but he didn't seem too
interested in a Russian dossier put
together by a foreign national that was
full of lies that was disseminated to
the public by leaks to the press and
also used to spy on opposition party
campaign based on Russian lies I like
those answers
yep no you're right I think there were
three takeaways from today no new
information no clues and no obstruction
after all the investigation that Bob
Miller did the second thing was he
resigned he told us that he was stepping
down and then third I think he doesn't
want to testify so if he comes that'll
be up to Jerry Nadler but there are lots
of questions to ask and the key ones I
think are where you were just at Shawn
this dossier because before they went to
the FISA Court in October of 2016 they
knew all kinds of things about the
author of that dossier Christopher
Steele they knew he was desperate this
was communicated by Bruce or to the FBI
he was desperate to stop Trump and they
didn't tell the court that information
didn't tell the court who paid for the
document name of
campaign those are key questions that we
need answers to the good news is the
bill bar is doing an investigation and I
think he's going to get the answers we
know that between the inspector general
between now mr. Durham now the Attorney
General and others the Avalanche is
coming you know of more than I do I wish
you would sneak the information to me
but you you kind of like more you don't
give me what I want to know thank you so
much Jim Jordan